I did a survey called the Great Bridge
psychopath survey
and the survey was unique in a sense
that what I wanted to find out was what
were the most Psychopathic professions
in the UK so I was on a radio show and
we decided to launch this on a radio
show now this the survey wasn't done
very scientifically because I didn't
actually think it was going to be that
big but it turned out it was quite big
uh indeed
um so what I did I said to people right
here's a little test and we might do
this test on you guys we will okay
um to find out where you are on the
psychopathic Spectrum but what I would
also like you to do is just jot down
your occupation so what I wanted to do
was I wanted to
um correlate occupations with
psychopathy levels and it became known
as a Great British psychopath survey
um and the results are really
interesting
yeah yeah yeah yeah
um uh yeah
um
so you will be very uh grateful to know
the stand-up commanders aren't in here
um but that's because there's not enough
of them around yeah statistic to be
statistically valid you've got to have
enough people saying that that's why
politics aren't in apologies a lot of
people obviously know all about
politicians uh well of the common
professions yeah these are the top ones
a friend of mine always talks about
politicians and says you know actually
of course well you know even I say you
know in order to be you know if you're
if you're going to be a politician any
kind of politicism is going to be pretty
high on the psychopathic Spectrum even
the ones you think are nice yeah
um and a friend of mine says the keys in
the word politics it's derived from two
words Polly uh the ancient Greek many
many and ticks being blood sucking so
anyway but anyway back to the survey yes
um number one with CEOs yep yep perhaps
not surprisingly number two lawyers yep
um number three media TV radio yeah
that's not such a big surprise actually
because it's a very Cutthroat World
currencies ideas it's very easy to Nick
ideas and you've got a lot of times
you're in a state of flux
um things in a state of flux you've got
to think quickly sales people perhaps
not surprisingly surgeons were number
five surgeon's really interesting
actually
um because
um
I did a talk once and I presented this
table
and there was a surgeon in the audience
who came up to me afterwards and he said
Kev uh I've got no doubt that actually
surgeons are in there but I think
actually you could be a bit more nuanced
here because there are now I think it's
about 12 or 13 different sub-disciplines
of surgery within the surgery bracket
and he said I think you might find that
some
uh brackets might be higher than others
um and we were going to run a study to
find out whether that was the case
um but various things got in the way
covid being one of them uh we may well
do this next year uh but his hypothesis
his hunch was that the
three uh surgical disciplines it would
be most harm a psychopathic Spectrum
would be Neurosurgery
cardiothoracic and orthopedic surgery
orthopedic surgery is pretty brutal if
you've seen orthopedic surgeons at work
they have to really do some pretty nasty
things to me you know and if you see
those you know I have 24 hours in a e
and you've got some with a broken bone
they've got to kind of twist that you
know even though the person's in under
analysis say local anesthetic but
they're still feeling it you've got to
be able to do that that's not you know
not everybody can can do that but he he
reckon that neurosurgery cardiothoracic
and orthopedic surgery would be the top
three
neurosurgery is very interesting because
neurosurgery you've got it's the only
branch of surgery where if you make a
mistake in the brain you could leave a
person permanently disabled or blind or
incapacitated or kill them of course but
in terms of like leaving the the kind of
the corollaries the the of of of
invalidity that you could leave a person
in if if an operation doesn't go well
there's no other branch of surgery
really like that and the you know
margins of error between crucial
capillaries is very very small
um
so that's when you're a hot
cardiothoracic surgery obviously
um and Orthopedics
um I spoke to one surgeon uh when I was
writing wisdom of psychopaths and I said
well you know what is the what's the big
difference between people that are great
in surgery and people who are just
merely good
and he had no hesitation I've spoken to
other surgeons about this no hesitation
talking and he answered straight away he
said it's the ability to make a crucial
decision under pressure
it's not technical ability
um a lot of consultant surgeons will
admit that actually the people who are
studying under them uh some of the
junior surgeons are actually technically
better but it's the ability to make a
tough call Under Pressure it's decision
making that separates out the top
surgeons from the the surgeons that
aren't so great
um
interesting just come back to lawyers
who are number two and then I'll go
through the rest of the list
um it's really interesting so lawyers
I'd interviewed a lawyer when I was
writing uh flypnosis which was the book
prior to wisdom of psychopaths and again
it was the same question what's the
difference between a great law and a
good lawyer and this guy
with a a pupil Master which is basically
like he ran his own Chambers in central
London
um and the chambers it was like a
teaching it was like a teaching Hospital
only in law these are chambers where
people come in from you know your
universities with your first class
degrees in law to learn how to be a
barrister
uh so he said well Kevin said you know
if people are coming to the into the
chambers he said they're all the top
people from you know your top
universities he said so the ability to
um get your head around a a crucial case
very very quickly all the detailed
nuances of it that's a given that's just
entry level having like a photographic
memory again same thing he said High
Intelligence obviously
um he said but the one thing that
separates out a great lawyer from a good
lawyer is something you really can't
teach and he said it's the ability to
tell a story naturally
and he said I'll never forget this and
this is really interesting this is again
why psychopaths are very good at
persuasion
he said you know what he said
information travels around the brain
like electricity around a circuit takes
the path of least resistance
so if you and I come up against each
other in court and the jury's over there
and you are able to present the pieces
the facts of the case you are able to
arrange him in a format that makes them
travel round the brains of the jury
faster than my Arrangement you're going
to win
whether you're right or wrong that's the
way it works so uh that was so you can
see why law is number two you see why
surgeons number five uh journalists
number six
uh the police number seven that's not
too surprising
um actually you know some police work
you know you've you know you've got to
be pretty tough you've got to you know
you've got it's you know some some you
know when you're on a front line or
you're investigating certain things
you've got to be you know you can't be
shrinking violet really in the police a
lot of evidence to show that um people
that work in so-called hero professions
which are police the ambulance and
emergency services and the military are
higher on the psychopathic Spectrum uh
than the general population uh now I'll
skip a because we'll come back to a
number nine is chefs
that is worrying yeah uh but again if
you think you know high pressure yeah
closed environment you've got a lot of
heat you've got a lot of pressure you
seem to manage you're gonna absolutely
right there's one yep excellently so
chefs and number 10 this is why the
surveys kind of fell down a little bit
civil servants so that that's a
catch-all that could be anything but
that's because because I didn't think it
was going to fly the the categories of
professions weren't that great I have
run an experiment again get more results
next year
um and a couple of million people filled
it out online so we'll have a we'll have
a proper look at this next year but
we'll come back to number eight
number eight the clergy church people
you didn't you didn't expect that museum
um now I didn't at the time
in hindsight a few years have passed now
since this came out
in hindsight it's not that surprising
because a lot of scandals have come out
about the church uh also the church The
more I've looked into it it's just like
pretty much any other business
um and it involves power over people
there is an uncontroversial phrase and
the church is like any otherwise it is
well I'll tell you something even more
chilling Constantine I mean there was a
church person quite an eminent Church
person who I interviewed once and he
turned around to me and he said one of
the most chilling things anyone had ever
said to me and he says Kev I don't
believe in God I'm just good at him
now that is chilling I don't believe in
God I'm just good enough now that is
pretty awful now I'm not digging church
people out because of course there's
always rotten apples in every barrel but
that was a pretty chilling thing if you
can manipulate God so that allows you to
have power over other people
that's pretty Psychopathic
um and of course you know like I said it
is churches like any other business says
power hierarchy says all kinds of things
and you're going to go up the ladder
using the techniques that you would use
in any other business because if you
happen to be good at God then you're
going to get up there the world is run
by Psychopaths
foreign
[Music]